and just who are you
oh I've been dubbed Minnie names by many
people
a ruler
a conqueror
he who remains
a jerk
but it's it's not as simple
as a name
[Music]
eons ago
before the TVA a variant of myself lived
on Earth in the 31st century
he was a scientist and he discovered
that there were universes stacked
on top of the zone
at the same time
other versions of us were learning the
same thing
naturally they made contact and
for a while there was peace narcissistic
self-congratulatory piece
I love your shoes I love your hair oh
man nice nose thanks man
Etc
they they Share technology
and knowledge
using the best of their universes to
improve the others
however
not every
version of me
was so
pure of heart
some of us
new worlds
meant only one thing new lands to be
conquered
the peace
into all out War each variant fighting
to preserve their universe and
annihilate
the others
this is almost the end
ladies and gentlemen of everything and
everyone
time Keepers came along and saved us all
[Music]
no no no this is where we diverge from
the Dogma that first variant encounters
a creature
created from all the tares in reality
capable of consuming time and space
itself a creature
you both know
Elias
bingo
I harnessed the beast's power and begin
experimenting on it
[Music]
I weaponized
Elias
and I ended I ended the multiversal war
once I isolated our timeline
all I have to do is manage the flow of
time and prevent any further branches
hence
the TVA hence the timekeepers in a
highly efficient bureaucracy hence ages
and ages of cosmic Harmony hence
you're welcome
he came to kill the devil right
well guess what
I keep you safe
and
if you think I'm
evil well
just wait
till you meet bye variance
[Music]